First up--
keeping up Trump-earances.
Keeping up Trump-earances.
(applause and cheering)
Since screeching hobo's
filthy lice-ravaged ball sack
that's been dragged over a
urine-soaked truck stop toilet
and repeatedly slapped
with a greasy maggot-covered
slice of pizza,
pulled out of a flaming Dumpster
and covered
in mutant deer ticks,
created in a steroid factory
after the technicians
were up all night getting buzzed
off cough syrup,
Donald Trump, uh,
announced his candidacy...
(applause and cheering)
...the Internet can't get enough
of digging up his embarrassing
old television appearances.
What's the latest Trump clip
to go viral?
A: Trump awkwardly
playing beach volleyball?
B: Trump awkwardly playing air
guitar at a Cheap Trick concert?
C: Trump awkwardly sacrificing
a goat
in order to please
the Ancient Dark Gods? Annie.
Uh, Trump awkwardly playing air
guitar at a Cheap Trick concert.
Let's find out.
Here it is, Your Moment of Zen.
-WOMAN: Nice serve from Feiffer.
-(Trump groans)
MAN:
Wow.
(indistinct chatter)
-Yeah!
-(whistle blowing)
-Well, his hat looks great.
-(laughter)
I like that spry teenage boy
who introduced the clip.
Who was that young man?
LEDERMAN:
He did such a good job.
How could he think
he'd hit a volleyball
with those little pin hands,
honestly?
(laughter)
How does he look
worse back then?
METZGER:
That's another good question.
Every girl that, like,
wants to be a gold digger,
like, these are the guys
you have to (bleep).
-Like, guys who look like this.
-Oh, yeah. Yeah.
-Just finish grad school.
-HARDWICK: Yeah.
Well...
Here's a slightly
more dynamic Vine
complete with
a Top Gun soundtrack
that Kyle Griffin
posted to Twitter.
♪ I'd say it was
the right time... ♪
(laughter)
JACKSON:
It looks like Matteo Lane.
LEDERMAN:
I love it.
♪ Highway to the safety zone. ♪
Who needs shirtless
Tom Cruise when you got those
perky man boobs bouncing up and
down in that saucy polo shirt.
Oh, is it out?
No, it's (bleep) tucked
all the way in.
Way in those jeans.